y tu cerebro es la vida te invito a que
hagas un punto conmigo a mi infancia
tenía usuarios mi hermana 6 cuando un
día nuestros padres nos dan la gran
noticia de que viajaríamos a disney este
maravilloso parque de diversiones donde
nos vamos a encontrar con los personajes
con los que crecimos los llevamos a ver
decíamos a pedir sus autógrafos y los
jonas subiera todos esos juegos
maravillosos se llegó el día viajamos a
disney la pasamos padrísimo nos
compramos todas las cosas bien así por
haber préstamos a la ciudad de chihuahua
de donde somos y sólo queríamos sombras
queríamos ponernos la playera la ciudad
era la diadema la pluma absolutamente
todo
una semana después de hacer este
increíble viaje la vida nos daría todas
las razones para nunca volver a celebrar
todo comenzó el 14 de agosto de 2000
durante toda la noche hubo una fuga de
gas en mi casa en la mañana siguiente mi
papá salió voy temprano a trabajar y ver
con ella nos despertamos mi casa era de
dos pisos bajamos llegamos a la cocina y
nos comenzamos a hacer de desayuno
con este ruido mi mamá se despertó y
sabía que algo no estaba bien
cuando sale de la recámara escucha y
volverás en toda la casa sabe que lo que
sigue es que la casa no está component y
tobago pateando para ver de dónde
proviene la fuga
ten en cuenta que es el cuarto de
servicio donde están las personas que
nuestras políticas comienza a tocar a
gritar su nombre tratar de abrir la
puerta y no responde señal que por la
cantidad de la cervecería sale mi alma
corriendo de la casa y en ese preciso
momento está el vecino a punto de
subirse a su carro a su coche para irse
a trabajar le dice lo que está pasando y
el vecino le dice no te preocupes sacan
las niñas y todo eso
el destino vendrá abre la puerta saca la
ayuda de servicio y cuando estamos
cruzando la puerta principal de nuestra
casa se genera la explosión
el gas acumulado el oxígeno de abrir la
puerta y las estufas del 2000 tener un
delito prendido esas tres cosas generan
la institución y lo que hace es buscar
salidas y salidas a las puertas
pasaron tres segundos cuando salieron
todos nuestros vecinos saber qué era lo
que había pasado y el 15 de agosto del
2000 no se ha parado en el fuego
completo con esas mangueras con los que
regar los nuestros sacar de versiones de
nuestro árbol
una vez
[Música]
la vecina de alfombras y dejándolos muy
estresados
habla con mi papá cuando el teléfono es
lo que llega la ayuda densidad constante
en el piso de la cocina de la vecina
y la cuarta en seguida de ella y por
primera vez a los ocho años de plantear
la posible de morir
y nos vamos a morir me contesta que no
nos van a poner mucha forma de lo
necesario
llegan los servicios de mudanzas para
médicos bomberos y nos llevan al primer
sí
no reciben una serie de doctores que no
tenían nada que hacer
el grado de quemaduras era tal que mi
papá no tengo idea de qué hacer
comienzan a hacer todo todo lo necesario
para salvarnos la vida entramos a una
operación nos dejan prácticamente en
piel viva se empiezan las discusiones
negociaciones ya donde nos tenemos que
ir y nos trasladan a eeuu llegamos a
eeuu y nos inducen a un coma que dura
más o menos de 3 a 4 meses en este
momento quién tomaba todas las
decisiones quien firmaba cada formato de
que podíamos morir en una operación en
un nuevo tratamiento era mi padre él era
quien sostenía a toda su familia porque
estábamos a punto de morir y no
quedarnos por acá
después de tres meses de estar luchando
entre la vida y la muerte logramos
sobrevivir las tres y comenzamos un
proceso de recuperar nuestra vida muy
lento muy doloroso con más de 60
operaciones en el cuerpo regresando a
chihuahua sin tener casa la habíamos
perdido de volver a comenzar
absolutamente todo de nuevo pasa el
tiempo y conforme va avanzando vamos
recuperando un poquito nuestra vida y
está a punto de cumplir un año de este
accidente sabes los aniversarios son
temas fuertes en la vida de todo ser
humano incluso los psicólogos dicen que
los vuelos generalmente hay que
transitar todo el año para ver qué es lo
que pasa se comienza a llegar la fecha
de este aniversario de aquel accidente y
mis papás hacen tres cosas con nosotros
la primera es que mandan publicar en el
periódico un escrito de agradecimiento a
todas las personas que nos ayudaron
durante este accidente la segunda es que
organizan una misa para agradecer y en
este evento de la misa nos llevan a
comprarnos ropa especial 3 cuando uno
tiene un evento particularmente especial
se pone guapo se arregla se alista
teníamos nueve años y siete cuando mis
papás nos llevaron a comprar ropa para
ese día donde agradeceríamos la vida
y la tercera cosa que mis papás hicieron
con nosotros es que nos llevaron a
disney nos volvieron a llevar a disney y
sabes lo que nos decían nuestros papás
vamos a celebrar la vida el mensaje tan
profundo que nos estaban regalando a mi
hermana ya mí no lo podíamos entender
esa edad éramos unas niñas pero el
tesoro era que la vida se celebra aún
pese a las adversidades
y entonces quiero contarte que en este
viaje yo encontraré una filosofía de
vida que ahora te voy a compartir con el
corazón en la mano y que espero que te
sirva para el resto de tu vida en ese
viaje no podía entenderlo pero años
después rescataría esta filosofía que te
la voy a ejemplificar con estas dos
fotos del lado derecho está la foto
antes del accidente y del lado izquierdo
está la foto después del accidente antes
del accidente nos hospedamos en un hotel
muy lejos del parque porque entre más
lejos es más
y llegamos a este parque había un ticket
para poder subirte rápido a los juegos
que cree en mi papá no nos compró por
claro nos compró la ciudad era la
playera la diadema se imaginan así que
tenemos que hacer muchísima fila y
esperar tiempo para subir a cada juego
después del accidente llegamos a este
parque muy diferente un nuevo cuerpo
teníamos en mi caso 90% de cuerpo con
cicatrices unos trajes especiales una
silla de rueda que nos acompañaba a cada
uno de esos juegos
y en este en esta ocasión que llegamos
después del accidente pasó algo muy
curioso en qué hotel creen que nos
hospedamos en el de disney y adicional
no necesitábamos ningún ticket porque se
nos veían las quemaduras porque traíamos
la silla de ruedas y nos dejaban a pasar
absolutamente a todo rapidísimo y
entonces años después entendí que la
vida siempre juega a nuestro favor
y entonces empecé a sacarle jugo a las
quemaduras desde las cosas más burdas
como nunca hacer fila porque decía que
me dolía estar parada o cuántas
ocasiones he estado yo en mi cama de
repente y ya estoy a punto de dormir
acomodada rica lista y me da sed y hay
que bajar por agua y entonces volteo con
mi marido y le digo amor me traes agua y
me dice no baja tú y yo amor estoy
quemada y baja por agua
imagínate que llego a la estética estoy
a punto de tomar un avión para otra
plática ted que vi que se iba a grabar
yo quería tener las uñas pintadas así
que llegó a la estética casi que
corriendo tengo dos hijos y llegó y le
digo por favor me podrían pintar las
uñas voltea a ver la gente me dice no
puedo faltan 20 minutos para que la
persona que hizo cita llegue y yo no
alcanzo a terminar en 20 minutos y yo si
alcanzas porque sólo tengo 7 dedos bueno
pásale y ahora saben que mi hermano me
acaba de preguntar hace tres días me
dijo luisa cuando tú te pintas las uñas
te cobran lo mismo
y dije claro me han robado toda mi vida
o sea de verdad ahora la próxima vez si
voy a pedir un descuento que muy
seguramente me lo darán y ya lo voy a
contar en la próxima conferencia así que
entendí que la vida jugaba a mi favor y
que había todas estas ventajas mundanas
pero también había ventajas
profundamente especiales y espirituales
como que en cada lugar al que voy la
gente me mira y de solo mirarme la gente
puede aprender cómo que puedo verme en
el espejo y puedo disfrutar y saber en
carne viva que la vida me ha regalado
una segunda oportunidad como que puedo
mejorar y puedo hacer mi propio concepto
de belleza para mí para las mujeres de
mi familia para mi hija para mis amigas
y la vida constantemente está jugando a
nuestro favor y sabes cuando empecé a
dar esta plática en mi mente decía vivir
celebrando la vida tiene tres puntos que
quiero compartir t
el primero es amar la vida en su
totalidad lo bueno
lo bonito lo feo lo oscuro lo luminoso
hay veces que nos queremos quedar solo
con una parte de la vida con me propuso
matrimonio padrísimo en un avión veinte
mil velas pero no queremos los
conflictos que existen en la pareja el
helado maravilloso que disfruto con los
amigos pero que no haya tráfico en la
vida
gane corrió un maratón pero no me
lesioné nos queremos quedar sólo con una
parte la vida es estas dos cosas tenemos
que amar la vida en su totalidad lo
bueno lo malo todo forma parte de vivir
celebrando la vida es amar la vida como
es lo segundo es que vivir celebrando la
vida es transformar el dolor en arte en
el arte de bajar 10 kilos después de una
decepción amorosa en el arte de correr
un maratón cuando en tu vida habías
hecho ejercicio en el arte de poner una
fundación cuando un hijo fallece en el
arte de escribir un libro en el arte de
inventar una plática en el arte de tocar
vidas en el arte de hacer una segunda
carrera el dolor no se puede estancar en
el cuerpo el dolor tiene que moverse
tiene que salir tiene que ser arte en
nuestra vida porque estará presente en
muchos momentos de nuestra vida y lo
tercero
es observar esa jugada a nuestro favor
la vida constantemente está jugando a
nuestro favor en este momento la vida de
todos los que estamos aquí está jugando
a nuestro favor
hay un músculo maravilloso que está
bombeando sangre a cada parte de nuestro
cuerpo que nos está permitiendo seguir
aquí hay dos pulmones que nos están
dando aire que nos permiten respirar y
saben la maravilla de eso vas a regresar
a tu casa abrazar a tus hijos tienes la
posibilidad de escuchar las platicas de
leer un libro de hacer los cambios que
necesitas de por fin lanzarte a hacer
esa empresa que tiene seis años pensando
en la mente la vida es un regalo y hoy
te voy a dejar con una pregunta que
espero que te lo aprendes al corazón y
te la lleves para que hagas los cambios
necesarios y tú celebras la vida gracias
[Aplausos]